Cecile Richards is entering her final
weeks at the helm of Planned Parenthood
the organization provides health care
programs like birth control cancer
screening pregnancy care and abortion
services to more than 2 million people
at more than 600 centers nationwide for
12 years Richards fought for women's
health care and organized campaigns to
protect Planned Parenthood's federal and
state funding
she will step down as president next
month she shares her own story for the
first time in her new book it's called
make trouble standing up and speaking
out and finding the courage to leave to
lead rather you could say leave this we
go it's published by touchstone that's
an imprint of Simon & Schuster a
division of CBS Cecile Richards good
morning to you good to see you good
morning it's been a twelve years how
would you describe it as you as you're
settling into your last week and why now
do you think it's time to go well it's
an incredible organization of course we
just celebrated our 100th anniversary
and it's been an enormous honor we
provide health care to one in five women
in this country and so it's hard to
leave but I'm ready to step aside and
have someone else take on their
responsibilities at a time where I think
we're incredibly strong in this in this
country and I think it's important as
you point out you provide health care
but for so many people Cecile they hear
Planned Parenthood and it's like this
it's very polarizing and very divisive
for a lot of people because they only
concentrate on the word abortion what do
you say about that well I mean again I
think we do more to prevent unintended
pregnancy than any organization in this
country and we always have it was
interesting Gail I just saw Fox News
poll out last week they did with the
Wall Street Journal that plan paired it
was the most popular organization in the
country of the groups that they polled
so for most women in this country and a
lot of men planned parent actually isn't
a problem it's more of a solution
you said it's not a political issue you
said it's a health care issue that's
correct I mean folks don't come to us
with to make a political statement they
come because they want access to
affordable health care and we're proud
to provide it all across America and
more than 600 health centers and federal
funding is so important for the
organization the president in his most
recent budget said never again he was
reluctant to sign that one of the
reasons obviously it was for funding for
organizations like Planned Parenthood
that was included in this recent budget
but there are concerns that that won't
be included in
budgets to come are you concerned about
that as you hand over the reins actually
because of the outpouring of support of
people across the country many of them
former and current Planned Parenthood
patients I feel really good about where
we are and we had bipartisan support in
the United States Senate that kept our
doors open last year and is again I
think as more and more folks have
focused on what it would mean when you
talk about defunding Planned period it
really means blocking women from getting
birth control cancer screenings and for
many women
we're the only health care provider that
they have you tell an interesting story
about meeting with Jared and Ivanka
early on in the after the election to
talk about plan I thought that was a
very interesting conversation will you
share that sure well and you can read
more in the book I think it's kind of a
behind-the-scenes look at you know they
I'd heard that they were interested in
meeting to learn more about Planned
Parenthood and I would do anything go
anywhere talk to anyone about the
important care that we provide so I took
my husband actually because I wanted
somebody else with me and we we sat and
talked to them but it really seemed
pretty clear that they just wanted to
make a political deal they and wanted us
to quit providing abortion services to
women in America didn't they say we
could guarantee funding if you say
you'll you'll stop you'll stop abortion
that's basically what they said and I
just said we will never turn our backs
on women in America it's a legal service
and Plus as you say no federal funding
goes for abortion services so though I
was very disappointed in the outcome of
the meeting I have been incredibly
encouraged again at the outpouring of
people who support Planned Parenthood
and that's really why our doors have
stayed open this last year what do you
make of the polarization around abortion
rights in politics today I mean
Democrats there used to be pro-life
democrats in the Democratic Party right
now you cannot be against abortion
rights and survive as a Democrat that's
happened over time why do you think that
it I actually don't think that's right I
think that the there's a difference of
people in America see which is the game
of their own feelings personal feelings
about abortion and it is a very personal
topic and I certainly respect that but
it's different to say that you want the
government to tell women and pregnant
people what they can do and that's where
I think actually there is overwhelming
support now for Roe versus Wade the
highest that there's ever been in this
kind
including among Republicans so because
it's the difference between respecting
people's personal opinion and what do
you want the government to actually do
but do you think if you're a Democrat
who agrees on restrictions of abortion
of some kind that you will have success
in the Democratic Party well I mean I
don't know there are people running all
across the country I will tell you one
thing that has been encouraging this
year and I write about it in my book is
the record number of women running for
office I have never seen the outpouring
of women being not only candidates but
activists I think it's an exciting time
frankly I think of and if we got finally
got half of Congress could get pregnant
we would quit fighting about birth
control and planned parent and we'd move
on to some other issues well I think
it's so appropriate that the name of
your book is called make trouble because
you talked about as a little kid you
refused in class to say the Lord's
Prayer and then later in seventh grade
you wore a black armband to protest the
Vietnam War and we're called to the
principal's office right that's been
kind of my history of course I talk
about in the book as well growing up
with like Ann Richards as my mother's
mother yeah who went on to become the
first progressive woman governor ever in
the state of Texas talk a little bit
about what was like raising activist
kids but it's like being pregnant with
twins and trying to go on the campaign
trail when there's no more maternity
clothes that could possibly fit you so I
hope this book is both a memoir but also
a little bit of a call to action for
people who want to make a difference in
the world but I was fortunate enough to
meet your mother when she was governor
of my home state of Texas and I'm
curious she was never one to hold back
her thoughts right and she spoke her
mind what would she think about the
current political landscape right now in
this country I think what mom would feel
is the incredibly excited about the
number of women who are now standing up
speaking out whether it's me too whether
it's time's up whether it is women
running for office and I know we've seen
that and one of the things I'll write
about in my book is the amazing women
including many young women I've met
along the trail this year and she'd
really be proud of her her kids or
grandkids my daughter Lily Adams who now
works for Kamala Harris a fantastic
United States Senator and the world is
changing I think women are shifting the
shifting the ground everywhere and mom
would love that
women running for office does that mean
Cecile Richards running for office
well maybe Never Say Never but I'm
really excited in these next few months
to make sure
that women are not only running for
office but they are registered to vote
and that they're turning out in November
I think women have the opportunity to
change the landscape and change the
direction of America
all right make trouble yeah and you said
make trouble never ends troublemaking
never ends you say that's right
interesting to see your next chapter
thank you Thank You Gayle thanks sir
yeah good to see you thank you Richards
make trouble is on sale tomorrow